[Applause]
If you've been uh trying to learn
hyperloops and you got to a point where
you can go into them, but you can't seem
to get out the other side, I want you to
try this tip and tell me if it works. It
goes like
this. You're going to start with a one
pi. Like a lot of things I do, one poi.
You're going to take uh your fingers of
your other hand, po in the left hand,
fingers in the right, just so we're
doing the same thing. And at first, just
flip the
poi up through that hoop you make with
your
arms. Get used to that. And notice if
you don't if you don't flip it enough,
you could go clink. And that's one of
the things that can go wrong. I'll show
you that with the poi in a moment. So,
you need enough energy to make the flip
work.
Then what you're going to do is
this. As you finish the flip, your right
fingers, you're going to pretend it's a
po and you're going to just go into a
weave.Oop. So you're going to go flip
and run it along this arm. Flip and then
cross over it. Boom. Boom. That might
make more sense in a
moment. Now, this is going to be a
little harder, but if you mess with this
for 10 minutes, it might get you through
this issue.
You're going to make the PO kind of
short. You're going to hold your left
poi here. And you're going to see how
you can take your right poi and you can
catch it. And with a little practice,
you're going to be able to flip your
left poi over the top. Now, that'll go
wrong uh a bunch of times probably where
it'll go like this and you'll just make
a knot, right? But we're breaking this
down to where we can see what's going
on. You'll need enough energy to have
both poi go flip and make it over the
top. Flip. So, it's going to be right
poi, left poi, jumping like a fish up
out of the middle and coming down the
other
side. Once that works and you've managed
to go flip and both
poi to make them not tangle up again at
the bottom
here, the right PO is going to
scoot up through here along the left arm
and the outside and you'll go into a
weave. So you'll go flip into a weave.
So it's a real step-by-step thing. Um,
first you need to make sure you're super
comfortable doing this. Just going from
the outside to in between the arms to
the other outside. So from the left, the
middle, the right, the middle, the left.
Sometimes people are uh find that
difficult at first. So you need to
practice
it. Then you may you need this has to be
fairly consistent where you can get the
both the po to go flip and they both
make it
over. And once that's
working, boom, you'll be able to go into
a weave. You just go flip, come to the
left, and into a
weave. So now you're really close.
Because if you go from
here, boom, into a weave, what's going
to change is instead of starting static
where you're just hanging the poi and
catching it, you're going to go from a
weave. And every time the right goes to
cross over, you could instead crash into
the left pi. So at first, just see it's
the same thing. So there, there's your
P. Oh, boom. That's where you're going
to hit it. And then it's going to be
like
this. So we're breaking it into the
pieces. So you go from the weave and
there it is. See where it's going to be?
Weave, you're going to cross, weave,
you're going to cross, weave, and you
just crash in. and come out the other
side. So that's uh I've seen this work
for some people. I would love your
feedback and whether it works for you.
So it's really a matter of being patient
with each step. So this needs to be
successful few times, bunch of times and
then you can go on and then you can put
it all
together. All right. So, I'm going to be
building a resource on uh Hyperloops
because I the Hyperloops for everyone
project. Um today I came out to realized
I need to get organized. So, let me know
how that goes. Um I'm super curious and
I will keep putting these videos up if
they're
[Applause]
helpful. Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]